今日は弾み社長です
ちょっと真面目な動画というかなんか結成多分咲かせてはいけない空気なんであの
真面目に今日は行かせていただくんですけども僕ユーチューバー初めて
結構な数の心霊スポット行ったりオラっぽいな儀式をしてみたり
結構なんか交流デーに取り憑かれるというかよくだようなことを結構して言っているん
ですよ
まあ好きなんだけどねもちろん好きなんでやってるんですけどもなんで心霊スポットで
儀式のかしちゃうかっていうと芸的な体験をしてみたいっていうのがあっても心のどこ
かにあるんですよ
なので僕はもう心霊スポットガンガン行っちゃうし今後も誰も生き続けると思うんです
が
本当に大丈夫なのかと逆に僕がはなんかそういう例力がなさすぎて最強すぎて今度に
イケてるのか
ちょっとわかんないちょっとしたら今はいくこと阿部だかもしれないんですよねこの夏
もたくさん神ですこといきたいなと思ってるんですけどもそのままではいかんだと思っ
たので今回熊本県の方からガチの霊媒師の方を呼ばせていただきました時
名刺もらったんですけどもう金融のお守りですね桂の霊視カウンセラーのマヤ卑弥呼様
という方に来ていただいております結構ガチで今回占ってもらうというかちょっと
いろいろ今の私の村が霊的な状況とこの神ですことに行っていいのか僕は泥が見れるの
かどうかとかもうまとめていろんなことを
がちの方に聞いていきたいと思いますでは
可愛いんですね
だけで本日は霊媒す
なんかスピリチュアルカウンセラーはい
別名るーバイス基本的にお祓いとかそういうのできないわけじゃないですけど
まあ新規のお客様はお断りしております
なログがない前卑弥呼さん今日はよろしくお願い書よろしくお願い致します
本当にあの動画を撮ってますて僕に打つ
心霊スポットに行くのがすごい好きなんですよ
もみました
やばいですかね
[音楽]
自分としてはどうなんでしょ行ってみて
こうなんかが見えるとかか
とかくは危ないんじゃないっていうの
あったりしますかあんまないですね
なんかどこかで見たいと思っている方も言ってるんですけど
映像
強い映像を取れたらいいなという何か起きたら嬉しいなという気持ちが優先しちゃって
いつも言ってます
どちらかと言うとず
遅くかあなた実際はもともと感受性が強い方だと思います
なのでご見える度か私たち高は
マーレイが見えるどうか何か効果貼ったものが見えるとかっていうのはあくまでも患者
性が強くなった人がまあ私たちみたいな形でにょこさせていただくという形で
あなたのば人の気持ちにおそらく b 館で書けるんです
の介護1の流れですね空気感とかそういうのがおそらくかなりでいいんか
なんかどちらかというとわざと図太くしているところがある
なんかものすごく神経質な方なんですねなので見えないって言うより感覚が感じるはず
です鳥肌が立ってみたりとか
寒気がしたりとかちょっとこれ以上撮影すると危ないんじゃないかなっていう危機感
ですねそういったが感じられてるんじゃないかなと思います
ただそれを自分の中で誤魔化しているはい
ところがあるかなと思いますよねこちらとしてい
マーブないなあと思った時はもう速やかに止めていただいた方が
枚のうちには
関わらなくていいのかなとなるほどの道を待っている時とか情緒不安定でコーチてたり
とか指ようにいやいらしているとか
そういうときはまり金を
徐々にもそのジェッツはズームダメあどういう時は逆にフラットな時に行ったほうが
正常範囲んの感覚なんでいる可能性が高いと思います
なのはそう伊予みようと思うと焦るので余計に見えないんですねまあそういうことか
自分がフラットな時に参ってみようかなぐらいの感覚で1点
ですねその雰囲気を楽しい神な形でいいかもしれないんですけど渡すと個人的には
ちょっと楽しむのもいかがな物かあずっ
狂うっな悪いかレイターともう仕事衣装から仕方がないと思うんですけども
鹿カレーとあーですねちょっと横線交代でもしてですねお手合わせ
ポー自身が食べ
たいものとまぁを戦後大抵上げても
お手を合わせているすいませんでしてじゃない
申し訳無かったですねいう形で行くにを上げしてからお帰りになった方が良いかなっ
ちなみになんですけどなく今って何かついてますか
ついてないあなたは基本ていつかないですあなたはどちらかで人を受け入れないと思い
ます
受け入れないな
それは人がこう仲良くしようと思って近づいてきても
いやちょっと待っていっていう形でちょっと一方背負う国と思うんです
よくご存じですねこう人に就く人っていうのはとにかく人にすごく優しく系道場すぐ
するタイプです
なのにあなたの場合同情する所かどちらかいたうあなたの場合てそれを行うことだと
思うんですね往生する相手がどうもできないじゃないですかまあそう
どうもできないことに同乗することで変えて自分が正
マイナスになってしまうぜスナッ
部分が出ちゃうのにあなたは基本的にものすごく気が小さくっていう怖がりさんだと
思うんですよなのでやっぱりそういったことがあると
やっぱどうしても自分の中で辛くなっちゃうから
地下スカイじゃないけど距離多いじゃうところがあると思う
あなたが作っておきはよほど弱ってる時でしょうね
なるほどなるほどなのでやっぱり大勢ていくなら誰かがケガするとか
まあその後に事故に遭うとかなんかちょっとずっと不吉なことが大きい部とか遠いたを
不吉なことが何回も何回も大きい始めるんだったらそれはちょっと危ないかもね8
うーん
皆さんぼ
国は
つかないみたいですで覚えていいことなんですか
つかないというのはどちら来ていいでしょうね周りから振り回されないに住むという
ことだうーん
自分らしい生き方さえ見つけることで切れると横に言うと取り憑かれることがいいし今
はされることが入っていうのはありますね独身でスポット行った時の決まりごととして
聞いたことあるんですけど
家に直帰したらダメっ
よく聞くんですよあれほんとですかはいそうです
いつもコンビニ寄ってるんですけど正解ですか
基本的に方位を見てくださいねご自身のご自宅を出るとするならばどっち方向に向かっ
て言ってるかでスタート地点が真ん中としたらどちらに身なのか東なのか来たんだ
どちらかを
きちんと確認した上で行かれた方がいい
でその反対ルートで通って帰って来てください
逆方向から今行かなきゃいけないそれなんでストレートでそのまま行っちゃうなら
ストレートに戻ってくるとダメなんですよ道教えるんですよ
ストレートじゃなくって自分が中心としたラマストレートで言ったなら早くに違う方向
で帰ってくるよ
形でちょっとぐるっと回って帰って来てもらった方がいいですよ
旅には弓よりも含みないです
永久者とかをイメージしていただくといいと思います霊柩車がストレートに行きません
相談ですぐるっと回って火葬場に入って今度はもどって来るときにまた反対ま終えて
帰ってきう
もうちょっと参考してもらうといいのかなと思いませんんそういうところ
動きをつけます少し腸が弱ってますよね
ブーブーも実家さあさっきからもドアが気になめし
ます
ねえちょっと人のか通ってないの人影が見えたりとかするので大分ちょっと寄ってる
なあっていうのがあなたよりかはこの家が私は気になりますね
音といい
冷蔵庫カップなりたんですよでしょうねえーなんかやっぱり連れてきてるんでしょうね
ちょっと僕は大丈夫ですかあなたは大丈夫だけどここに来る来ても居心地悪いと思い
ます
何か9 em です環境きちっとすることです関係が悪いのでそれとカーテンを朝一番
にですねとこ全部カーテンとか玄関から全部開けていただいてまぁ30分くらい空気の
入れ替えと太陽の近くをあげるって事ですねはい
金にするとやっぱ杉藤あるんですよね
気持ちだねんですけど家に金を置いた方がいい
ああなるほどあなた自身に金を使うとあんまり良くない a これ努力の
なぜかといったお金が良く出ていきます
のことなので入るけど全部流れていくという
入った分だけ流れていくっていう経路ができちゃう
なのでそれを止めたくてと金をちゃんとしたいっていうのであれば
に入った
お金を流れがよくなるようにキーうん
5ねしょうだとか
推奨顔の画像とか見せてもそんな方を占う事って可能ですか
いきますまぁ今度ですかユーチューバー何かどちらで占っていただきましょう
課金さんという方がいらっしゃいます今年30歳
まあどちらか鼻の下が少し長いでしょてこう口がぷっくりしてるっていうのを
すごく女性に好かれる顔大
女性に疲れるけどもただストーカーとかに追われやすいから気をつけたほうがいいん
ですよね要するに誰にでもこの方も優しくしちゃうねそれが書いてちょっと辛い方に
するのかなって思うんですね不振
ねちょっともうちょっと0政治に強くなってもらいたい花というのはちょっと心配です
か
光が精神的に強くなってくださいこの方どうですかどちらかいてをてと右手とほしい
ですね
に気をつけたほうがいいです日ちょっと腰この方はどちらがで右側がこの方弱いにょ
するときだいたい飯田
だから髪の毛がう
文面とそれはちょっと遊びロゴを入れると帰ってゆけに勘違いされる正確になります
本当はすごくねガマズミですごく仕事をコツコツされる方なのになんかチャラそうとか
出しから遊んでそうとカップの形グレーとかの方がおそらくすごく
ビジネスとかでもうまくいく可能性なんですよねああああなツアー髪の毛グリーンにし
てくださいちょい課金さんっな色さんこの人は
はカラーのどちらかいては首から下が弱いのねぜ方よ姫濃度とかすごくやるあのされる
と火病協したりと思いの道ちょっといい乾きやすいとか痛めやすい
気を付けられた方がいいかなと
[音楽]
ん
また3病院に行って下さい対面も一人だけないんですよ
声生まれにくらいにくらい
すごく暗い雰囲気なのでどちらかでもうちょっと明るくしたりとか
あの洋服とかも明るめの洋服ですねはい寒色系というかです
そういった服を着た方がすぐ顔の表情が明るくなるのである
気持ち的にちょっと上向きになるかなと
zard 軽くが苦手ならば本物げですね
馬の眼鏡のふち位だったりというかまぁちょっと
ウンチだったり靴下のようちょっと変えてみるとか
そういうふうにしてもらうと素朴
明るくなるのかなと思います
何と言うダーマー靴下の色変えてください
あなたの髪の毛一本植毛でねぇてください
俺したっ
あなたやっぱり胃が弱ってるね大日なるんじぇすとじゃあに植えて言っている
楽しいとこにもやし楽しいません評価された
大丈夫です
い
ここが少し終わってるからねここが痛くなったりとか
なんか違うとか変なところに行ったりは医師名スポットところとこっち側が重くなっ
たり痛みが走ったりとかなんかちょっとここが寒きを感じたりとかするとあなたなんて
のはここだもんで